[Musica]
una bella storia da raccontare
potrebbe sembrare un titolo un po
leggerino
per non dire banale che però è lo
vedrete alla fine di questo mio
intervento è tutto un programma
almeno per me è sempre stato così ed è
tuttora così e anzi mi spingo oltre
avviare una bella storia da raccontare
rappresenta uno dei temi centrali della
mia vita
per scoprire quale potere le mie storie
le storie delle persone che hanno
viaggiato con me hanno avuto sulla mia
sulle loro vite
vi invito appunto ad un viaggio alla
fine di questo viaggio
il titolo che ho dato al mio intervento
verrà trasformato in
il diritto ad avere una bella storia da
raccontare e vi rendete conto che
davvero alla fine scopriremo anche un po
tutto un programma
le persone che mi conoscono
credo che anzitutto mi connettano con
una serie di grandi risultati come per
esempio quello di assidui olimpidi del
millennio una gara disputata in
condizioni atmosferiche a dir poco
proibitiva abbia strappato quell'oro
davvero è rimasto nella memoria delle
persone
e poi mi ricordano per quell oro che non
ho vinto sul bacino di regata a pechino
dove la ucraina inna osypenko mi ha
preceduta di quattro millesimi 4
millesimi non si vedono ad occhio nudo
non si vedono più o meno sul fotofinish
e il fatto che la giuria abbia deciso di
non dare un ora ed è alimentato il
dibattito in italia e questo ad avere un
contributo ad un grande aumento della
mia notorietà e poi ancora forse mi
ricordano che è quello 8
partecipazioni olimpiche otto
partecipazioni olimpiche e per esempio
non sono tanti tanti anni
una vita spesa in canoa nel frattempo è
stato eguagliato questo record ciò non
toglie che
mi è passata dall acqua sotto i ponti in
questo questo periodo per scoprire però
il
dove sono nate le mie storie note
suonate le mie storie infatti dobbiamo
voglio voglio portarvi a due domande
voglio disquisire con voi su due domande
dove nascono le belle storie e poi da
cosa e da chi possono dipendere le belle
storie
sapere dove sono nate quelle belle
storie che ho appena citato
facciamo un tuffo in un passato ancor
più lontano nel
1976 a rimini nella città di m dove io
ho esordito nel mio sport e assieme a
mia sorella alle sue amiche perché io
andavo sempre dietro a mia sorella lei
era più grandi di medion anno e mi ha
sempre
difesa perché sono stata una bambina
abbastanza spericolata e allora ci
recavamo tre quattro volte nella
settimana nella nostra società
ovviamente più allenarci però poi se non
fosse stato di allenatore che ci
intimava di uscire no prima
dell'andamento di andare in barca dopo
l'andamento perché doveva chiudere la
sede noi saremo rimaste nel nello
spogliatoio
nello spogliatoio si sbaglia [ __ ] che è
stata una specie di luogo di ricreazione
per noi perché intanto che ci
preparavamo ci raccontavamo tutte le
cose della nostra vita il tema più
quotato potete immaginare a quell'età
noah tra 12 e 15 anni e siamo partite
con primo sguardo timido ricambiato a
volte sì a volte no poi il primo bacio
il primo fidanzatino
la prima grande
cotta
la prima il primo grande fine di uno di
una storia prima grande film di una
storia
ancora parlavamo del della scuola degli
insegnanti e oggi rimarco proprio la
tipologia di storie che ci sono state
a quei tempi perché penso che siano
davvero caratteristiche per quell'età
che in cui non si è più bambine non sia
ancora adulte ed e.on età di transizione
che richiede a tutte le persone trovare
il proprio posto nella vita e perciò per
noi per me quello che ricordo come luogo
dove sono nate le mie storie erano
spogliatoio è bene poi è stata la volta
come posso dire
e lo dico perché non sono state subito
le belle storie sono state le storie
proprio dell'adolescenza storia anche
spesso cariche di preoccupazioni
disorientamento però il bello è stato
che l'epo abbiamo potuto condividere il
fatto poi di riina di ri narrarci di un
harakiri narrarci e di guardare alla
stessa storia
ogni volta da un punto di vista diverso
ha fatto sì che un po alla volta
avessero preso corpo e fossero datate di
senso le storie personali di ognuno di
noi la mia storia personale è stata
quella di una bambina che ha 15 anni si
è scoperta un grande talento al
veramente maniera inattesa da tutti
perché fino a quell'anno io avevo sempre
fatto solo la barca single ata che mi ha
dato e mi riteneva brava solo nella
barca
il primo anno ho fatto la gara singola
narratore mi aveva sempre reputata più
brava nella nella canoa doppia e poi
sono rimasti di stucco tutti io
l'allenatore la gente sul campo di
regata
e proprio anche per questo considero
quel primo grande risultato una sorta di
coincidenza perché come stavo dicendo no
per noi ancora lo sport non era quella
cosa che era per gli adulti no
risultato prestazione
e fatica
certo ci allenavamo per competere per
far fare le gare per migliorare eravamo
anche molto
felici di poter magari portare a casa
una medaglietta si sa che quell età e
l'età in cui lo sport serve per
socializzare
infatti per noi lo sport era quella
quell'attività era una cornice in cui
crescere insieme
poi ovviamente da quel primo risultato
in poi le cose hanno iniziato a cambiare
avevo 15 anni ed ero finita nel radar
della federazione è cosa succede mi
convocano mi convocano all
evento di selezione una selezione che
era fatta di prove multiple che
consisteva nel dover sollevare dei pesi
e fare un circuito di forza resistente
fare una lunga corsa
e 12 km mai nella mia vita prima di
allora avevo fatto 12 chilometri tutti
d'un pezzo li dovevo andare più forte
che mai ha detto sicuramente un morirò
quello è stato uno dei commenti espressi
nel nello spogliatoio non sopporta ma
poi scortata
prontamente scartata perché non
considerata un talento comprese
d'altronde come potevo competere con la
categoria junior nel momento in cui ero
ancora primo anno ragazze persino nata
in settembre e fici tre croci in segno
di ringraziamento per la tregua perché
tra me e me ho detto beh io sono sicura
che voglio davvero quel cambiamento che
avrebbe comportato il fatto di essere
convocata nella selezione junior però è
stata una tregua che ha durato poco
perché l'anno successivo sara è stata
convocata ad un summer camp
momento in cui ci potevamo ogni giorno
misurare con ragazze junior
che non ci consideravamo non ci
consideravano eravamo un po l'emozione
del momento noi le le le bambine i
pulcini
però io mi son messa accanto alla più
forte beate martin che poi sarebbe stata
diventata una grandissima mia amica e
cosa ha fatto con quei due grissini al
posto delle mie braccia
neanche un filo di muscolo da mettere da
parte mi mettevo accanto a lei che era
già molto ben posizionata al punto di
vista muscolare e ha cercato di produrre
la sua stessa velocità con quella poca
forza che avevo
poca spesa tanta resa si usa dire nel
nelle aziende e cosa è successo in
futuro avrebbero detto ma la idem a quel
grande dono di far scorrere la barca e
io ho sempre tozzi si aveva un grande
talento un grande dono finché un giorno
mi sono ricordata di quegli episodi e ho
iniziato a dire non ho guardate che è
stata una conquista stata una conquista
facendomi bastare le poche risorse ho
sviluppato una tecnica poco dispendiosa
che poi sarebbe stata la mia
caratteristica è mio punto di forza per
tutta la carriera
ebbene quell'anno abbiamo affari
campionati tedeschi a monaco dove da
secondo una ragazza non avevo più
avversarie e anche nella categoria
giugno sono arrivata seconda dietro alla
mitica beate martin è quella che vi
abbiamo aprivi ho appena presentato
e da quel momento in poi le cose sono
davvero cambiate in che in che senso
ora io che lui considerato un talento
sono entrata proprio anche nel negli
inviti nelle convocazioni presso centro
federale ha gi sport mentre le amiche
della società che non erano state
considerate talenti e che poi erano
anche alle prese con l'apprendistato
credo che anche in questa zona sia molto
conosciuto questa forma di preparazione
alla professione no dopo la seconda
superiore si fa questo apprendistato e
così è anche il sistema in germania loro
ha iniziato con quello e con quello è
finita la loro carriera e quel grande
crack in germania quella quell'abbandono
dallo sport giovanile che ha lamentiamo
anche qui in italia attorno a questa età
germania stato decisamente anche dettato
da questa contingenza e cosa è successo
è successo che
dalle belle chiacchiere con le amiche
che erano proprio anche
costitutive di un senso di un'identità
sono passata alla totale solitudine
risale per fortuna a quei tempi anche
una cosa che non avrei più abbandonata
nella mia vita la scrittura di un diario
e perciò mi sono confidata con questo
diario e quando all'età di 42 anni ho
scritto la mia autobiografia ho potuto
risalire a quelle emozioni e quelle
sensazioni a quella disperazione che ho
anche vissuto a tratti a quelle tali
e perciò sono stata un grande conflitto
è innanzitutto c era da consiliare sport
in studio chi pratica sport chi segue
giovani atleti sa che questo è spesso un
punto di rottura e poi ero molto
combattuta perché voleva essere una
ragazza normale come le amiche che ad
ormai avevano smesso abbiamo nel
fidanzatino andavano in discoteca
e avevano tempo libero mentre io avevo
queste le talento da gestire da
sviluppare di cogestire perché d'aver
non sapevo se doveva essere grata di
questo dono perché mi chiedeva in
continuazione
se prezzo da pagare per questa cosa
fosse davvero congruo avevo i miei
pensieri dubbi
perciò per che cosa significava come vi
dicevo la solitudine
significava doversi allenare allenare
allenare e dopo quello questo facevo
allenarmi perciò la mia vita era
assegnata proprio da questi allenamenti
in continuazione
ok troviamo detto dove nascono le belle
storie da raccontare la mia storia poi è
stata bella
e come se come è successo che si sia
trasformato in una storia bella
allora innanzitutto
a scanso di alibi
è dipeso da me ovviamente perché un
certo punto ho detto
ragazzi miei non sono d'accordo che lo
sport debba essere sacrificio non solo
d'accordo che per lo spot si debba
rinunciare a una vita privata non sono
d'accordo che si debba sempre ed
esclusivamente
essere stanchi una fatica fine a se
stesso e ha avuto il coraggio di
cambiare ho preso sua fat armi e bagagli
sono auto in italia
ho iniziato ad allenarmi assieme a mio
marito che non ne aveva mai saputo della
ca no però abbiamo studiato insieme
abbiamo avuto il coraggio di inventarci
una nuova storia quindi è dipesa dalla
mia scelta coraggiosa e dalla sua scelta
car coraggiosa quindi da chi dipende
anche dalle persone che si mettono a
disposizione e che ci aiutano e che
studiano e che studiano e qui noi
arriviamo a quella trasformazione del
titolo che adesso sta diventando il
diritto di avviare una bella storia da
raccontare
dove mi sono accorta di questa di questa
distinzione
allora un bel giorno in un evento
pubblico racconto la mia storia
c'è che effettivamente ai tratti del
viaggio dell'eroe
superato queste resistenze ho vinto
queste resistenze grazie a questo ho
vinto e infatti lui ci va ma signora
idem lei non d non trova che lei abbia
vinto grazie al fatto di aver superato
quegli ostacoli è affatto plini dalla
mia testa ho detto guardi che secondo me
io non ho vinto grazie a quegli ostacoli
ho vinto nonostante di quelli nonostante
quegli ostacoli e sa cosa ti dico non le
dico quante persone quante altre
compagne di strada hanno proprio smesso
per un paradigma obsoleto per un'idea
superata quella del fatto dello sport
che debba essere sacrificio fatica
rinuncia
tristezza fatica fine se stessa
dico nuovamente
e allora lì ha preso proprio anche forma
questa questa mia azione verso una
ridefinizione delle mie azioni e sono
diventata con veniva detto anche in
apertura mi sono laureata in psicologia
perché volevo comprendere i fondamenti
scientifici di un buon intervento nelle
nella crescita che che accompagna alla
crescita delle persone
dall'infanzia all'adolescenza deb
passaggi molto delicati che richiedono
davvero molte competenze e devo dire che
a quei tempi i miei allenatori non
sapevano ancora di intelligenza emotiva
delle intelligenze multiple
dell'importanza delle emozioni piacevoli
per un buon apprendimento e per una
buona motivazione
oggi noi queste cose le sappiamo e ciò
nonostante spesso rimangono disattese e
allora oggi
davvero
tentato un mio tema centrale questa
frase ogni giovane e anzi vado oltre
ogni persona il diritto di avere una
bella storia da raccontare e come la lo
si garantisce questo diritto attraverso
il dovere delle persone che plastic
incidono e supporto da dovrebbero
supportare i bambini abbiano le
conoscenze le comete competenze
necessarie per sapere che cos'è
l'intervento giusto
ovviamente non tutti possono disporre
del pieno delle competenze delle
conoscenze però una buona ricetta nel
frattempo allora se tutti noi
spesso dico in ogni istante ma spesso ci
chiedessimo
ma io sto facendo di tutto perché poi un
giorno io occhi
da me seguito avrà una bella storia da
raccontare
come posso averne cura già proprio
questa empatia questo questo persino
questo immaginarsi sull'asse del tempo
ci pone di fronte a far cimentare una
serie di domande che ci costringono ad
indagare a studiare a trovare le
risposte di cui oggi noi disponiamo ecco
questo è proprio il mio invito quella di
avere cura cura delle storie nostre
personali delle persone vicino a noi del
collega al lavoro e nella fattispecie
dei giovani soggetti in crescita
[Applauso]